how do you envision or how could we
envision a model where physics could be
sustainable and that physicists who do
contribute could receive financial
remuneration is there a kind of a
Marketplace solution to the problem of
sustainability the reality is number one
we don't know what's going to work
ultimately and number two is there's a
scrum to get there think about the
original transistor how much does the
original transistor look like the 10
billion if it's a coat hanger with some
chicken wire and then there's a piece of
chewing gum I'll put a clip of it right
here everyone said I had that idea I
came up with that thing and it was the
thing that someone else turned into a
big business and even when you have the
same thing you can give the same IP or
the same technology or the same thing to
10 different entrepreneurs or 10
different businesses or 10 different
investors and nine of them won't work
and maybe one of them will work so you
never know what path what team and what
it's going to take to take a concept or
a discovery or an invention and make it
into a business that generates money
[Music]